Now that Avengers: Endgame is finally out
in theaters, directors Joe and Anthony Russo
have been able to freely expand on some of
the movie's plot details.
One of these, which came to light at a recent
Q&A session for Endgame, has even hinted that
future Marvel movies could be the setting
for a major comeback.
According to Slashfilm, someone in attendance
at the Q&A asked the Russos to run through
exactly what happened with the Infinity Stones
at the start of the movie.
The directors confirmed that, three weeks
after his initial snap, Thanos utilized the
Infinity Stones once again but this time to
destroy them, preventing them from being used
to reverse his work.
Thanos using the Stones to destroy themselves
was one of the major inciting incidents of
Endgame, but there's one little issue with
it: time doesn't function correctly without
them.
While the heroes are snatching up the Infinity
Stones in the past, the Ancient One explains
to Professor Hulk that you can't just pluck
a Stone from a certain place in time and not
return it, as that would create a branch alternate
timeline overrun with disorder.
Just...not the kind of disorder shown in Back
to the Future.
Time travel!
“No.”
The Ancient One tells Hulk that the Infinity
Stones are "essential to the flow of time,"
and that they must be replaced at the exact
moment in time from which they are taken.
So if the Stones are so important to preserving
a properly functioning timeline, why didn't
the universe devolve into complete chaos after
Thanos destroyed them?
Well, as the Russos explained, Thanos didn't
actually wipe the Infinity Stones out of existence
he just reduced them to atoms.
The Russos indicated that this means the Stones
are still out there, floating around on "an
atomic level."
Though they may not be tangible or fit for
use in their current state, the Infinity Stones
remain a part of the universe and will continue
to keep things in order.
This would suggest that the Infinity Stones
could appear again in a future Marvel movie.
Plenty of characters have wielded the Infinity
Gauntlet throughout Marvel's history so there's
a ton of source material for writers and filmmakers
to use if they wish to bring back the Stones.
If anyone's going to be the key to the Infinity
Stones' return, there's a good chance it's
going to be Adam Warlock, who has been tied
to the Stones since their print debut.
For some time, Adam was the primary bearer
of the Infinity Stones and the Infinity Gauntlet,
but what's more important is that he has a
pretty messy history with Thanos and has served
as the Living Tribunal, a cosmic entity that
preserves equilibrium amongst all realities
in the Marvel Comics Multiverse.
The kicker here?
Both Avengers: Endgame and its predecessor,
Avengers: Infinity War, were meant to include
the Living Tribunal, and Adam himself was
close to being included in Infinity War.
So could Marvel be saving Adam for Phase 4
of the MCU, in the hope of folding him into
the franchise off the back of these atomic
Infinity Stones?
It seems plausible.
Marvel could even bring the Stones back and
introduce Adam all in one movie.
Infinity War and Endgame screenwriters Christopher
Markus and Stephen McFeely have previously
mentioned that the character can't just show
up from nowhere and Marvel would have to,
quote, "practically make an Adam Warlock movie"
to bring the character into the universe.
But, if it happened, that would be an ideal
moment to revisit the Infinity Stones.
Even if a solo movie isn't in the cards for
Adam, however, he's likely to play a pivotal
role in the MCU moving forward.
And if the Infinity Stones never appear in
the MCU again which could be the case at least
fans won't lose any more sleep wondering just
what the heck happened to them.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.